Connor you found probably the only used
product in Japan which was your fridge
I'll let you tell the story but it
definitely was not in immaculate shape
you know we had spent a lot of money on
moving right as anyone knows we think is
very expensive
and I'd heard of these like sayonara
sales as they're called people who move
from Japan they basically sell all their
stuff article yes ourself and so they
sell all their stuff on Craigslist and
Maylene kept telling me a book walker
kept telling me like dude bio buy your
stuff on Craigslist
it's like dirt cheap I thought well you
know it's great idea mainly Wow cooler
out colder out here hi Anna you know I
thought all right well you know Japanese
people are really great with like
keeping their stuff immaculate so yeah I
order I speaks on Craigslist a sauna
fridge and a laundry machine is we call
it device McGeady yeah I bought it for
like it was like 50 bucks right for a
fridge in a morgue that's already read
right right but there was some people
who are giving that stuff away for free
yeah yeah cuz they were like we're gonna
get charged by the local cops oh yeah so
I didn't pay for anything else not the
moving for your anything so you were
there with my housemate turned up yeah
like a guy from like New Zealand yeah
you just turned up and he was like
alright I'll [ __ ] yeah I'll [ __ ]
install the store if we and they say he
was like I'll vote for you and I think I
discussed with the post on Craigslist
they were gonna charge like a ten on a
friend story yeah so the guy was like oh
[ __ ] it mate so he installed it and then
I got like you remember I come like like
angry [ __ ] texts off the person off
crisis they were bombarding my fire I
picked up the phone and then there was
like an Indian woman shouting at me
being like why didn't you pay him the
1000 yen and I was like what the [ __ ]
shut up I was like yeah and so I was
like I was just like hang up the phone I
was like yeah no he left now what the
[ __ ] you want me to do yeah yeah stop
shouting at me I'm like I told her
message I leave you've sent me one more
message shouting at me I'm blocking
then they given out hard block use don't
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and the the guy
uh the the Kiwi called me up he's like
alright mate loosen ear she wants the
money I'm gonna come back and get it and
I was like I fine I'll just give you the
Tanner I don't care and you just all
stop calling yeah yeah I just want to
like enjoy my evening yeah
sorry met him at the conbini gave him
the tenner and then you know went back
next day I open my fridge there's like
five cockroaches in my fridge it was
like I was like holy [ __ ] right no-one
didn't want a foreigner in the house
right imagine being the only foreigner
in your building and that guy has
cockroach it's like the cleanest country
in the rocky world
I swear to claim the [ __ ] who brought
cockroach I bought a copper spray I
[ __ ] tore this fridge apart right I
literally thought you know like the felt
that you have on fridges yeah yeah I
tore all that [ __ ] off I took everything
out I bleached the [ __ ] out of this
thing like this my house must have smelt
like a murder scene yeah right I
bleached the hell out of this thing and
it was the most vile thing like you know
the the felt thing right I've shaken out
and like maybe like a hundred
cockroaches must have fell out I don't
even want to know the living conditions
of the person who sold me this fridge
but [ __ ] you if you ever watch those you
are horrible
do not sell people your fridges if they
are how can you get cockroaches in the
most cleanest country and I've ever been
to there we're on the streets here and
you don't see any [ __ ] rubbish so
there were there are less cockroaches in
like the back of like a [ __ ] game
easier damn they were yeah like so that
was my first experience buying used in
Japan yeah it was awful because I just
thought like god dammit
like I just got this house and I've
cockroach yeah yeah and so I had to like
scour my whole apartment just making
sure these cockroaches didn't go
anywhere and I and like months after I
kept finding one or two and I'm like how
I bleached
everything like there is no reason these
things should be existing as cockroaches
one I wanna maybe thought you got rid of
them all this floor so now I got rid of
the fridge because I just thought enough
is enough this thing looks disgusting I
threw it out yeah it was gross inside it
look like singer like a home
let's take your apartment probably has a
cockroach infection that you just put
into no no no no it's it's it's
somewhere in the building
I got my god I got all those [ __ ]
understand I spent a lot of time